[Music]
hello and welcome to this video this is
the first video about the Rico's and
variation in this course and the
recursion starts with
these moves let's have a look so this is
an idea of three and yeah here white has
the fundamental choice between three
different moves I mean okay there are
some off beat once but three main moves
Knight f3 or Knight c3 or g3 and after
Knight f3 our repertoire suggestion is
to play d5 for Queens gambit and after
Knight c3 play the move Bishop before
with this a starting point of the
Rogozin um so we are basically combining
ideas from the nimza with Bishop before
with the Queens gambit declined
structure with d5 um in their chosen
White has a choice of lines available
and we have a couple of chapters in this
course to this custom and this is the
first chapter which is about the move
Bishop to g5 this is one of the most
popular moves and it's um quite a
logical one the bishop is developed on
its most terms act of looking square it
spinning the night which makes
particular sense here as we have already
put the Bishop on to before so there is
no Bishop e7 to naturally break this pin
um an important point however is that
after Bishop g5 there is a difference
between different like smooth now but
black basically has a choice now between
various systems that are fundamentally
different and we are going with the move
h6 in this repertoire the big point
about h6s that now White's Bishop needs
to commit itself take on f6 or play
Bishop H form um I think a big point
here for the h6 move is that white is
more or less forced to take on f6 as
Bishop age form is not particularly good
the only question of the bishop age
force if black can still equalize or if
black is already better we should
establish this first before we look into
Bishop takes f6 so Bishop age form and
now the move that is a problem for a
white is the capture on c4 we simply
take the pawn and here we see a big
difference between taking the pawn now
or the most perform we should briefly
check this black can take this pawn
which is also a fairly popular option
nowadays a transposed to the so called
DNA variation um and here he for is a
possibility and by far the main move
young black cannot directly use this
efore move for a certain tactic which is
possible yeah because now he for is
actually pretty awful because we have g5
and we basically win already now Bishop
g3 in 94 is a complete disaster
we win a second pawned important efore
pawn and we have immediate pressure here
on c3 so this is absolutely unplayable
and this is an important point because
efore is definitely the move that white
would want to play ideally but it
doesn't work and this means he has to
resort to other moves to now try to
regain the pawn and in many cases he
won't even manage so let's have a look
at some lights
he can play a3 immediately for some the
situation here we take and we simply
attack now the center with c5 black can
also triumph like b5 but this is a very
good and sensible continuation white now
has to be aware that Queen a fibers on
the agenda and with the bishop being on
edge for there is no natural cover of
the on with Bishop d2 so white will
should you reach this position probably
take on f6 to avoid the Queen a5 thing
but we are definitely not in any sort of
danger in this position b6 is a good way
to develop our bishop we will go to be 7
and later this
we had to put the night and it can put
it on to c6 sometimes go to a5 197 often
times we play on the C file in such a
structure Bishop e7 rook c8 can be a
good idea because here there are some
weaknesses to play against um after this
he form white has also tried to check
this is a typical move in the records
and white can't play Queen a for almost
all the time in the early most force 96
forcing this move knight c6 has its
upper downsides like um gets basically a
development move for free as Queen a4
it's not so useful for white in itself
the Queen is not well placed on inform
and on the other hand the knight is
blocking the C pawn and oftentimes we
want to play c5 which now doesn't work
oftentimes it's a good idea for black to
simply think of this move as something
that you should make use of somehow I
could try to play e5 for example so that
this can be a useful piece positioning
now YTM has tried moves on like a3 and
III we can check them after a three
we simply capture and now there is
important for a move to remember it's
not that intuitive the Queen to d5 this
is nice
we cover the pawn with the Queen and we
prepare b5 even with the tempo after a
sequence like this black is a pawn up
and it's absolutely um not clear if
white has anything like an adequate
compensation we get to Bishop to b7 our
development is not bad at all um this is
a three White has also tried III trying
to get the pawn back now but Bishop d7
is a very useful reply
this is an immediate threat that you
need to be aware of if white is now not
observant then he's hit with Knight
takes d4
for example after Bishop takes Knight
takes d4 this is very awful because the
queen capture obviously doesn't work so
Bishop d7 is an important reason was
that essentially you could beg him
essentially forces the Queen move the
Queen cannot stay on a form so what
usually retreats to c2 after which we
play b5 making use of the pin we can
simply play this move to keep the pawn
and again it's very questionable if why
it has enough for the pawn something
like there should be two a6 castles
Bishop d6 this was a free preview of our
entire one d4 course based on the
nimzo-indian and rock gozen available on
chess about calm thanks for watching and
see you soon
[Music]